muy buena tarde noche para usted qué
podemos esperar por parte de china en
esta conversación de presidentes
bueno no sabemos qué espera china de
esta conversación que de hecho fue
solicitada por eeuu lo que sí sabemos es
que llega indignada por dos razones
primero por las amenazas de sanciones de
eeuu y contestaba a un miembro del
gobierno chino en la prensa local que
responderán con fuerza si se producen y
segundo y mucho más grave con todas esas
informaciones que llegan de washington y
que aseguran que china se plantea el
envío de armas a rusia dice china que
son simples bulos con los que eeuu
intenta calificar la de aliada de rusia
y arruinar su posible papel de mediadora
no sabemos su postura pero es muy
improbable que vaya a desplazarse un
solo milímetro de la equidistancia es
improbable que bardem convenza a sí de
que se sume a las sanciones a las
condenas en la onu o que cambie su
retórica pero también es altamente
improbable que vaya a armar a rusia
porque iría en contra de los principios
de su política exterior de la
neutralidad que ha mostrado durante
estas tres semanas
arruinaría sin remedio sus relaciones
con la unión europea que para chinas son
prioritarias